hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal war
eine und jahr viele haben es beim
letzten mal richtig gesehen ich hatte
vergessen bei einem begrüßung zu machen
skandal es tut mir unendlich leid das
heutige video wird so eine art ich teste
mischung wandel wird zu wissen so was
dazwischen ich weiß nicht ganz genau was
jetzt sein wird ihr werdet in titel
lesen
ich habe nämlich tattoos bestellt die
ich heute ausprobieren möchte und nein
es ist nicht dieser typische tattoos
lief die man sich so an halloween oder
an fasching rüberziehen kann und dann
sieht man aus als ob man voll der harte
rocker ist es sind so eine tattoo
sticker wie man sie aus kaugummis kennt
oder aus ja diese goldenen kuh scheller
ich bin so ein freier mensch mit fehlern
auf meinem körper tattoos es sind
nämlich richtige tattoo artworks also so
richtige tattoos wie man sie kennt die
leute sie tragen die große und viele
tattoos haben und ich habe extra die
packung nicht aufgemacht weil ich um die
spoiler lassen wollte ob die qualität
gut ist wie die denn aussehen das testen
wir jetzt sehen wir jetzt zusammen
ach ja mein look ich wollte wie eine
rockerin wie eine zarte frau aussehen
ist mir gut gelungen ich weiß es ist
ganz ehrlich dieses bank sieht zwar
schön aus was die haft weil sowas fest
dass an dem kopf ist ich weiß auch dass
ich das früher so mit 16 getragen hat
und mich voll cool geführt hat und jetzt
erinnere ich mich langsam
das ist aber voll nervig war weil es
einem so auch die ohren weg drückt es
ist ja auch eigentlich jetzt passend zur
faschingszeit ich weiß nicht wo in
deutschland erlebt was bei euch gefeiert
wird aber wenn ihr also vielleicht mal
als rocker tattoo szene gehört
ausprobieren wollt hier habt ihr das sie
waren aber nicht so belegt die haben
glaube ich pro stück 10 euro gekostet
und ich dachte das video kann man selber
machen naja also privat ein bisschen
teuer ich zeige euch mal was so viele
tattoos gekauft habe
das war schon eines meiner lieblings
tattoos das ist so ein fuchs mit dem
mond und nach rosel also ein ganz
klassisches tattoo die qualität sieht
jetzt auch ganz ok aus nicht zehn euro
werde ich weiß noch nicht wie viel
dieses genau gekostet hat aber ich finds
also es ist auf jeden fall schön eine
schwalbe und ein anker und ein herz auch
eine sehr wohl klassisches tattoo sehr
schön oh ja das war ne selbst sagt ich
war doch unbedingt schwarz weiß hat uns
ausprobieren weil ihr ja sehen könnt ich
habe selber tattoos ist sind aber alles
bunte tattoos sind außer die tasse und
dieser vogel aber da ist halt auch nicht
viel auszumalen und ich habe sonst
konnte tattoos gehabt und das ist mal
ein schwarzmarkt hat ich habe vorher
noch nie so richtig klebe teams gesehen
die wirklich aus dem wie tattoos und
nicht weit
ihr wisst was ich meine
das ist richtig schön das ist unser tool
das würde ich mir wahrscheinlich auch
stechen lassen
ich bin mir bei menschen immer noch
nicht ganz sicher ob ich mir wirklich
ein gesicht und an den körper machen
möchte aber das sieht richtig schön aus
ach so viele wünschen sich auch ein
nagel update momentan habe ich mir major
drauf gemacht ich wollte jetzt mal ein
paar tage farblos sein kann ich noch
nicht ganz genau weiß was ich danach
machen möchte ich möchte so crazy
designs ausprobieren aber jetzt ist erst
mal basic [ __ ] angesagt ja hier haben
wir einen illuminaten ich weiß nicht was
ich mir dabei gedacht habe einen
dominanten tattoo mit rosen und einem
kompass ein kompass habe ich schon ich
glaube ich will tatsächlich die frau als
erstes ausprobieren so direkt gruson
problems schon große arme ausgelegt wenn
ihr eine kindheit hatte bist du jetzt
wie das funktioniert ich schneide so
drumherum und dann klingen fuß drauf als
ich angefangen habe mit tattoos machen
zu lassen wollte ich nur so einen vollen
arm haben damals war ich aber 18 und das
ist mittlerweile sechs jahre her
und deswegen bin ich mir nicht mehr ganz
sicher ob ich nicht auf den anderen arm
auch tattoos haben
was ich weiß ist dass ich auf den beinen
keine tattoos haben will
ich weiß nicht warum aber ich finde
nackte beine beine ohne tattoos
irgendwie schöner als ich 30
ich find auch den beiden passt irgendwie
nicht aber es ist ja nur meine
persönliche bei roswitha skal aus so das
tattoo kommt jetzt auch die stelle ja so
wie soll man das dann rumkriegen ok
funktioniert kann das hier oben nicht um
falten sind nicht für kurven gemacht
diese tattoos wasser und lappen weingart
ist es nicht auch eine gute art
herauszufinden ob man es mögen würde das
ist doch voll praktisch man holt sich so
bunte ähnliche tattoos wie man sie haben
möchte dann klebt sie drauf und wenn man
nach drei tagen merkte das gefällt einem
immer noch ja einfach tattoo motive die
du dir stechen lassen willst vorher als
tattoo ausdrucken lassen am ende des
probetrainings gibt es doch bestimmt
schon oder seid ihr bereit
david
[Musik]
oh mein gott es gut sehr gut aus oder
sieht aus wie ein richtiges würdet ihr
das jetzt bemerken wenn ich jetzt hier
sitzen würde das hört man doch nicht
merken dass ein kleber tourist oder hey
ich weiß ich habe beide arme tätowiert
ok nich unbedingt weitermachen nummer
zwei kommt jetzt hier
ich hätte mir vielleicht weil die arme
rasieren sollen ich freute mich aber
nicht die arme rasieren aus dem alter
bin ich raus so wisst ihr wie lange das
sonst dauert schmerzen und zeit und geld
und hier hast du einfach mal ganz schön
krass sorry wenn ich heute so oft an die
seite gucke ich möchte aber auch dass
natur sehen online er ich habe jetzt
schon bock auf ein neues tattoo geht es
schön kinder hier kommt ein fuchs
ich freue mich schon die nächsten tage
immer drin schrubben perfekte bewegung
vanessa hier passiert nichts neues so
müsste man auch mal in einem tattoo
laden reingehen hallo
naja ich kann mich auch mit tattoos ich
hab mir schon viele daran geklebt das
kann man auch mit seiner eltern drängten
so richtig casual einfach nach hause kam
mit natur hier mensch fed muss ich nach
vorne drücken
ich habe offiziell einen voll tätowiert
ich kann das tattoo mir hier drauf
machen
ich mache es wirklich leute und ich
mache es wirklich das letzte extrem
bunte krasse tattoo kommt auch meine
brust jetzt gibt es kein zurück mehr
oh mein gott geht das tief ist ich glaub
ich mag es jetzt habt ihr auf jeden fall
eine vollintegrierte vanessa ich weiß
wie ich das video meine klebe tattoos
versus echte tattoos was ist besser
die frage ist ganz schnell beantwortet
echte tipps sind besser aber der vorteil
dass du das ein paar schluss oder ein
paar tage trägt schon einmal so schlecht
und ich glaube ich möchte echten
schwarz-weiß zu tun
ich dachte ich bin jemand der luft und
der fuß haben wird aber dieser fuchs
hier den gefällt mir ich viel zu gut
wäre das wird für manche tätowierer geht
ich hab da so ein klebe tattoo auf
amazon gefunden und hätte das jetzt
gerne als tattoo in kleve tattoo von
amazon er ein kleines tattoo von amazon
in avon amazon ja gut ich hoffe euch das
video gefallen ist und wenn ja welche
sächsischen daumen nach oben jetzt wisst
ja auf jeden fall wie ich mit klebe
tattoos aussehe und ich würde sagen dass
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder sehen
wenn ich wieder in eine scheiß
ausprobiert noch weitere videos